in a strange way these
technologies
have always been entwined with spirit
you know that famous quote by arthur c
clarke
uh
any technology that you don't understand
is perceived as magic
and so shamanism is an effort to
manipulate the perceived forces of
nature
gnosticism
was a fantasy or a myth about the nature
of the human soul in relationship to the
world that maps easily over our
contemporary ability to do
virtual realities
uh probably the greatest boost occult
thinking ever got in all its centuries
of unfoldment was the discovery and
elaboration of an understanding of
electricity
you know we forget how
hard it would be imagine trying to think
about magic and
healing
and
sympathetic
mojo and all these things if you
completely lack to the concept of
electricity
as the renaissance did the renaissance
knew nothing of electricity and yet
marcelo facino and the florentine
platonus and all those people were able
to produce magical systems
the 19th century is the great century of
electromania and it's also the great
century of spiritualism all forms of
spiritualism became
intellectually
entertainable because people could see
electricity this mysterious hidden force
that they were told was in everything
you know they could trap it in bottles
and carry it around and cause their hair
to stand on end at one point under the
u.s capitol uh in the 1830s they
set up an apparatus so congressmen could
quote unquote take electricity
and people would go down into the
basement of the capital grab onto these
electrodes and say
wow
that's that's good stuff they're pushing
ben franklin was you know
a great experimentalist with electricity
and when he went to france to be
inducted into the french legion of honor
he was asked to serve on a commission to
study and report on mesmerism
and whether it was and of course
mesmerism
used electrical metaphors
very widely to convey its idea of what
was happening
so
yeah i think you know magic has always
striven for
effects which technology has achieved
marcilion talks about this in in a book
called
no
memories dreams reflections a book of
essays about how
the alchemical dreams of the 16th
century which were a universal medicine
prolongation of life
hermetic statues that would speak and
give all knowledge uh communication at a
distance all of these things have been
achieved in the 20th century through the
application of a reductionist science so
it's almost as though uh the dreams of
the occult are achievable but only at
the cost of uh abandoning the naive
epistemology that lies behind it
so in a way
all magic is technology that's what
clark was saying and on another level
all technology is magic
you know it's not for nothing that that
huge special effects company called
itself industrial light and magic
you know it's an understanding
that the mundane the industrial the
capital based can still be combined with
the magic
hope is that what these communication
technologies will make more accessible
to us and more
uh
corporeal paradoxically is our own
imaginations
that we need to
show each other the inside of our own
hands
and build art i mean
my conviction of this comes from the
fact that i know a lot about art
probably you do too i you know spend
time with it go to museums think about
it so far and so on and i've taken
lots of psychedelics and there's more
art
in my head
joe ordinary
than there is in
half the museums on this planet well how
then it's it's what's maddening is how
narrow the reduction valve is you know
we've been making art for 5 000 years
and what have we got we've got a few
museums full of some nice stuff but what
have we got in our heads
fifty thousand times more good stuff
but very hard to get out and really hard
to get out when you're carving it in
diorite and granite and
you know
but
somehow this
barrier between us and these realms of
art you don't even have to talk
philosophy you don't have to call it
the platonic realm of ideas or or
some higher imperium you just have to
say beauty there's a great deal of
beauty on the other side of this tiny
keyhole that we're looking through and
if technology gives us a way to open the
door and all waltz through dancing uh it
seems to me that would be a spiritual
renaissance that what happens at a
spiritual renaissance is by some means
the collective soul
becomes collectively known
like in the italian renaissance the
invention of oil painting allowed great
geniuses to portray the major themes
moving in the archetypal unconscious of
their patrons and populations who view
their paintings and themselves and it
it's a shared epiphany it's a spiritual
quest it's a group transformation but
it's it's driven by and led by the
revelation
of art i hope i live to see the day i
mean i don't care i don't know about
downloading consciousness into a machine
what i
would
be able to die happy with is a
technology that could capture
just a
snapshot
or a film clip of one's thoughts
so you know you would rig up on dmt or
psilocybin or something and when you
really got into the good stuff you hit
the record button
and have it and then you could come back
down with it and model it and adam break
it and move it around edit it explore
unpack certain parts my god the power of
art that could be created that way and
and again i it's ordinary people i'm
convinced it's not
what genius is is the ability to bring
it back not the ability to encounter it
every single one of us can encounter it
and that's very telling
and almost an argument for our divinity
because here we are at the end of some
long
darwinian evolution
tree of winnowing so that all we have
are what we need
and yet apparently one of the things we
need is a notion of alien beauty
just right behind your eyebrows seems to
me if that's something we must have in
our tool kit then
someone with greater intelligence than
us must know a lot more than we do about
the journey we're making
[Music]
[Music]
you